[موسيقى]
نعم سلمى شارع الحبيب بورقيبه كعادته في
هذه الذكرى وبهذه المناسبه يحتضن تحركات
مختلفه لعديد الاطراف المدنيه والسياسيه
بهذه
المناسبه لاطراف التي دعت اليوم الى
التحرك الى تنفيذ وقفات بشارع الحبيب
بورقيبه تحت مسميات ورسائل مختلفه رسائل
تؤكد من خلالها الاطراف المعارضه وايضا
المنظمات المدنيه التي تنفذ وقفاتها اليوم
في هذا الشارع تؤكد من خلالها تمسكها
برمزيه واهميه تاريخ الرابع عشر من يناير
عيد اللي الثوره او التونسيه وذلك في رد
على عدم اعتراف السلطات بهذا التاريخ موعد
رسميا وعيد الرسميه للثوره وذلك بوقت»
سياسي رسمي اصبح هذه مقتضى عيد الثوره
التونسيه يوم السابع عشر من ديسمبر ايضا
الرساله الثانيه التي توجهها على اطراف
المعارضه
للسلطه من خلال تحركها اليوم في شارع
الحبيب برجيبه هو مطالباتها بالرحيل
ومطالبه الرئيس قيس سعيد بالرحيل وهي
تعتبره بانه جزء من المشكل في تونس و بانه
اصل المشكل السياسي اليوم وبانه لا يمكن
حل هذه الاوضاع السياسيه وهمم ايضا ما
تتبعها من اوضاع اقتصاديه واجتماعيه الا
برحيل الرئيس همم قيس سعيد وفق موضوع
المعارضه التونسيه اذا هو مشهد استثنائي
ومناسبه استثنائيه يحيي من خلالها
من خلالها تونس هذا هذه الذكرى الثوره
التونسيه في ظل حاله انقسام
سياسي حاد وغير مسبوق منذ اعلان الرئيس
قيس سعيد في الخامس والعشرين من يوليو من
عام 2021 عن اجراءاته الاستثنائيه ذلك
التاريخ الذي اعلن همم من خلاله قيس سعيد
عديده الاجراءات السياسيه التي قلبت
موازين المشهد السياسي برمته في تونس ومنذ
ذلك التاريخ انقلب المشهد راسا على عقب في
تونس من كانوا في السلطه تحولوا الى
المعارضه واا تحولت السلطه الى المتحكمه
في مقاليد جميع السلطات التنفيذيه
والتشريعيه وذلك في ظل غياب برلمان همم
تونسي هذا البرلمان الذي سيتتشكل بصوره
جديده بعد انهاء الانتخابات التشريعيه
التي يتم دورها الاول في انتظار اتمام
الدوره الثانيه منها يوم التاسع والعشرين
الشهر الجاري ثم بعد ذلك سيتم انتخاب مجلس
الجهات والاقاليم الذي سيتقاسم الدور
التشريعي والوظيفه التشريعيه وفقا ما ينص
عليها الدستور الجديد مع كل من رئيس
الجمهوريه والمجلس النيابي القادم هذا
المشهد الذي تعتبره المعارضه خروجا عن
الشرعيه في تونس وانقلابا من الرئيس قيس
سعيد على الشرعيه وعلى المؤسسات الدستوريه
والديمقراطيه همم في تونس وهي تدعو اليوم
من خلال هذه التحركات التي تنفيذها في
الشارع بمختلف اطرافها المعارضه اليوم
تنفذ هذه التحركات وتدعو من خلال ذلك الى
استدعاء المسار الديمقراطي في تونس والى
رحيل الرئيس قيس